hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 1
episode 4 cripples bastards and broken
things the episode where jon snow meets
lifelong BFF Samwell Tarly the mountain
kills a guy in the hands tourney and
Catelyn Stark returns Tyrians favor of
designing the saddle for a crippled son
with a friendly citizen's arrest now I'm
stoked to be back working our way
through the earlier seasons of the show
pointing out all the interesting
connections and setups we missed the
first time around starting with this
opening dream scene with bran and
Winterfell standing practicing his
archery when he sees this raven with
three eyes now the scene is very toned
down adaptation from the dream sequence
in the book a game of Thrones let's
actually go over this and all the ways
the episode compared to the source
material in our segment um well in the
books so as I mentioned before in the
books the three-eyed crow appears to
brand in a far more surreal vision
soaring him high above the continent of
Westeros where he sees his family on the
Kings Road and beyond the wall and
Dragons stirring of the shadow lands of
Essos and then he wakes up form is coma
not before the vision like the show eyed
him do at the end of episode 2 actually
makes sense that the series would
restrain themselves on these cryptic
supernatural elements so early in the
run as we're still kind of getting to
know the world in the characters later
when Tyrion runs into Theon at
Winterfell he says this I still remember
seeing my father's fleet burn in
Lannisport I believe your uncle's were
responsible must have been a pretty
sight they're referring to the Greyjoy
rebellion the attempt by Theon's father
Baylon Greyjoy to secede from the Seven
Kingdoms nine years earlier which ended
in defeat when they were driven back to
Pyke this siege on Pyke actually comes
up later this episode with Jory and
Jamie two soldiers who helped quell that
rebellion by embracing this recent
history from the books these early
episodes firmly established the Seven
Kingdoms as naively optimistic about
their unity yeah it's not gonna last
this defeat is also the reason Theon is
in Winterfell he's being kept as a ward
by the Starks more or less a hostage to
prevent bail on gradually from any
future aggressions so tyrion reminding
Theon of this history is an insult but
also in a way goading Theon to take
control of his seemingly stagnant
position in life and to finally act just
like Tyrion did with Jon but more on
this later and then notice the reason
Jorah tells Danny that he sold slaves no
money on an expensive wife
where is she now in another place with
another man so in the books we learned
that Joris wife was Lin s Hightower who
grew impatient with her far less
luxurious life than she was used to
Ashley there's a very similar dilemma to
her cousin Steve Hightower Jorah went
into financial ruin tried to please Lin
S and while in exile she left him for
trigger or Mullen a rich merchant in the
free city of Lee's it seems she a gold
digger but in the books drawer also sees
Daenerys is very similar in appearance
to Lin s also in being way too young for
him however compared to lanessa Dany has
more easily adapted to a life in exile
without a silver spoon so to him Danny
is the low-maintenance Roadtrip wife he
always wanted speaking of creepy age
gaps little figure tells Sansa the
origin story of the mountain in the
Hound one evening Gregor found his
little brother playing with a toy by the
fire Gregor's toy Gregor never said a
word he just grabbed his brother by the
scruff of his neck and shoved his face
into the burning coals in the book this
goes down a little differently the Hound
actually runs into Sansa and tells her
this frightening story himself the crew
cited production reasons for this change
like maybe the actors couldn't be
available on set the same day but I like
how it now established is this
uncomfortably close relationship between
Sansa and Peter which will obviously
play a bigger role as the series goes on
actually let's move on here to be other
moments this episode with interesting
connections to future events but for
those of you who somehow haven't seen
the series or read the books you can
skip to this time to avoid any
discussion of later story beats okay
with the losers gone let's look at this
episode in hindsight okay so very early
in the episode when Theon enters
Brandt's chamber to bring him downstairs
notice how summer welcomes him now of
course in the moment we could see this
as some are being cautious against any
visitors let alone an outsider to the
family but in hindsight yeah this is
totally foreshadowing Theon's betrayal
of brand in season two when he sees his
Winterfell in fact this whole
interaction with a brand is more or less
repeated beat for beat when he does that
I think in your castle shield its Prince
Theon now did you hate us the whole time
actually I like out later this episode
Jamie also hints at this betrayal Theon
he's a good luck I doubt it
next Rob and Tyrion stents exchange is
interesting I'm not your boy Lannister
I'm Lord of Winterfell while my father
is away you might learn a Lords courtesy
as we'll see in seasons two and three
Robb ends up defying those old customs
when he breaks his vow to Walder Frey
and marries Talisa leading fraid to
offer him his version of a Lords
courtesy moving on to the city of vias
Dothraki we get this interesting sex
position scene between Doria and Viserys
that foreshadows two things first
there's this moment - nothing melted
like so many candles the fact that
Viserys reacted to getting burned here
tells us that despite his ravings he is
not a dragon and he can be burned as
Danny summed up to us after he got
cracked here's a new tracking fire
cannot kill that dragon
shortly after this Dorian says this I've
seen a man who could change the face the
way that other men change their clothes
Doria is almost certainly referring to
one of the faceless men jack in a gars
Colton Bravo's who we'll see in future
seasons in King's Landing Ned says this
to pycelle Izzy ruminates John Aaron's
death poison is a woman's weapon
pycelle ads that eunuchs are also known
to use poison casting suspicion on
various now the assumption was that the
woman who poisoned Jon Arryn was Cersei
but of course in season four we learned
that it was John's wife Liza Arryn you
gave me no chops and told me to follow
them into Jon's wine my husband's work
and this whole idea of poison being a
woman's weapon came back in a new
interesting way in the recent season
seven when Cersei delivered the Queen's
justice to ilaria sand by kissing her
daughter tongue in with poison lips
poetic punishment for ilaria doing the
same to her daughter Marcella
now in the next scene with Ned and Arya
listen closely the background oh he
needs to get his strength back first now
those are the bells of a Sept of Baelor
which as I pointed out my breakdown
so three also clang when Ned speaks to
Ari in a previous scene both cases it's
just a really cool way that the season
foreshadows aria hearing those bells in
the morning of Ned's execution now Ned
tells Aria about her future marrying a
noble Lord and having kids and Aria
responds this way it's not me Aria will
echo this brogue independence when she
reunites with her dire wolf rhyme area
in season 7 allowing her to run away
from a domestic life and then when
Littlefinger instructs Ned on the
numerous spies throughout the red cape
he gives him this ominous advice just
trusting me was the wisest thing you've
done since you climbed off your horse
Littlefinger is telling Ned that he's
going to betray him here so Ned's later
decision to confide it with Littlefinger
on his plan for after Robert's death was
a super dumb move let's actually close
out this in hindsight section by looking
at Ned's other huge mistakes this
episode right after Littlefinger warned
Ned that spies are watching him
everywhere he goes Ned says this DeJoria
outside the armory shouldn't be out here
alone there's no telling who has been
located also earlier this episode Ned
donates 20 of his own household guard to
Janos Slynt to help the city watch
something that catches a small council
by surprise because yeah
Ned is needlessly weakening his own
personal defences making it easy for the
City Watch to overpower them later then
towards the end of the episode when
Cersei meets with Ned she pretends to
make peace with him over the kingsroad
incident but Ned just refuses to play
along and rudely cuts her off what are
you doing yeah come on Ned just play
along and play the game for one second
Ned easily could have continued his
investigation quietly while doing the
bare minimum to endear Cersei and not to
call attention to his actions but not
this honorable northerner cannot do it
he has to openly confront Cersei
basically telling the Queen to her face
lady I'm coming for you yeah not a good
idea okay moving on from connections to
the future to the interesting parallels
to past moments in our segment callbacks
another scene that was actually written
to pat out the episode run time was this
one between Sansa and septem ordained in
the throne room and notice the Cadi
exchange between them I told you a
hundred times a diable shut up about it
this is
hey met a joke in a callback to episode
2 the writer of this episode Bryan
cogman suggested episode to be titled a
direwolf is no pet instead of the
kingsroad it's an actual title the
showrunner David Benioff hated that idea
so much that he ordered that no episode
could ever be called a direwolf is no
pet so it sounds like could enough
septum ordain here as a nod to that
inside joke later when Danny and Viserys
argue she snaps this at him you've no
right to a braid you won no victories
yet and if she finishes this line notice
how the camera lingers on Danny's braid
now this is a callback to Danny starting
to have her hair braided last episode
after her first victory of shutting down
her brother this braid will grow longer
and increasingly ornate as the series
goes on and later when John tells Sam
about his near first time notice the
name of the woman hole named Rose well
cool ahead good this is actually a
callback to earlier this episode I
assume this is the same rose and
Winterfell that Theon recommends to
Tyrion he lot red tights asks for us huh
Rose must be some woman I guess we know
where John got his thing for redheads
let's move on here - a few cultural
references in this episode and a brief
segment of under the influence first
back in that scene with Dorian Viserys
notice the names of the dragons that
Viserys lists there was geese gum and
valor ion Verma Thanks so Verma Thrax is
not one of the Targaryen dragons in the
Song of Ice and Fire books it's actually
added to this episode as an homage to
the dragon in a 1981 movie dragon slayer
the creators of the show including
george RR martin ranked dragon slayer as
a great fantasy film and a major
influence on the game of thrones another
interesting reference in this episode
came an Alliser Thorne spooky tale of
being stranded in the blizzard north of
the wall the horse is done first didn't
have enough to feed them to keep them
warm eating the horses was easy
believe it when we started to fall that
wasn't easy it's interesting to see how
genuinely haunted thorne looks while
revisiting this memory the writer
actually referred to this scene as the
Robert Shaw in Jaws scene saying that he
drew from Queens similarly haunted
monologue to the two younger man in Jaws
you know the thing about a shaggy like I
like how even John Williams scores seems
to have influenced Ramin Djawadi zweite
Walker theme yes sir to my all-time
favorite scores and I just never noticed
this connection okay let's move on to
talk about a few interesting visual
choices this episode looking closely at
some shots and our segment 2-minute
hands so when Sir Hugh dies this
horribly violent death during the joust
notice this little fly that buzzes
around the wound already sensing his
coming death this little morbid detail
really braced a life what is already a
visceral unsettlingly real death the
first time we really see someone bleed
out like this on the show in fact the
director didn't allow sophie Turner and
Maisie Williams on set during rehearsal
so that their reactions would be
genuinely shocked
kudos to Maisie for adding this little
glimmer of fascination on Arya's face as
she watches him die psycho but Dee gore
and the realism of this death makes a
promise that the Knights and the
Warriors of Game of Thrones don't go
down with clean cinematic deaths George
RR Martin's fantasy world is far more
cruel and then let's look closely at
this closing shot with Catlin arresting
Tyrion this man came into my house as a
guest and there conspired to murder my
son I call upon you to seize him so
fairly is amazing here this is actually
the scene she auditioned with to get the
role of Catelyn Stark but it's
interesting how this downward pointed
shot accentuates Tyrion smallness the
number of sorts here is totally
unnecessary to seize him he's impossibly
outmatched I think this image is a
really good illustration of how despite
his good intentions a world of taller
men will always see tyrion smallness as
a threat and that brings us to the
deeper meaning of this episode is
episode is titled cripples bastards and
broken things obviously taken from
Tyrians line early in the episode a
direct quote from George RR Martin's
book I've attend a spot in my heart
cripples bastards and broken things
Tyrion's empathy for the imperfect will
never win over the masses if anything it
makes them more despised
but it does Ally him with some
surprising fellow cripples bastards and
broken things ran John but also Theon re
watching these early episodes it's
interesting to see Tyrians role in
activating each of these misfit toys he
advises John to wear his bastard status
like Armour he supplies bran with his
first real step to a life of movement
and he even lights a fire under Theon
reminding him that he's a Greyjoy
beginning his journey to seek his
father's approval in tournament starts
and as we'll see throughout the series
in the world of Game of Thrones the
outcasts are the ones who bring about
the most change he's four but also Jaime
and later seasons Arya the Hound Brienne
these early episodes kind of misdirect
us into thinking that the Game of
Thrones will follow the classic fantasy
structure with Ned Catelyn and Robb
Stark leading the charge as the apparent
heroes but if you're paying attention
the true heroes changing the world in
discrete but powerful ways are the
cripples bastards and broken things
which of the Starks do you think are the
most foolish this episode Ned for his
sloppy investigation in King's Landing
Catelyn for arresting Tyrion or Robb for
alienating Tyrion and dismissing the old
customs that will come back to haunt end
I just love how much we used to support
these idiots this cast was just so
charming I want to know your thoughts so
comment down below or tweet me directly
at EI vas and follow new rock stars on
Twitter at new rockstars for updates on
her videos like and share this video
around trust me if this rewatch series
takes off we'll start doing these
classic breakdowns a lot more frequently
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of Game of Thrones and all the
stuff that you love and if you really
like us contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our donors especially
Wilhelmina eveson thanks for watching
bye